c'est en ce samedi la journée de la
jeunesse le président valéry giscard
d'estaing la clôturera par un discours
cet après midi porte de versailles le
président de la république visitera
auparavant l'immense exposition
consacrée aux problèmes des jeunes et à
propos des jeunes et plus précisément de
l'éducation des enfants et des
adolescents
le figaro magazine présente aujourd'hui
un sondage celui ci révèle que 86 % des
parents sont favorables à l'autorité et
même à la fessée et qu'ils sont contre
le laisser faire et le laisser aller
mais que veulent les adolescents et les
jeunes adultes de moins de 25 ans
dominique fleury a consulté toutes les
enquêtes récentes sur les jeunes des
enquêtes qui se recoupent les adultes ne
connaissent pas les jeunes
contrairement aux idées reçues aux
clichés qui ont toujours la vie dure les
jeunes en 1978 non rien de ces violents
de ces délinquants qui font souvent la
une de certains magazines inconnu dans
l'hexagone les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
toutes les enquêtes sérieuses le
confirme sont en majorité studieux
préoccupé par l'avenir et qui le
croirait vivent le plus souvent en bonne
intelligence avec leurs parents bref
l'adulte a souvent une image fausse
archi fausse de la jeunesse et en
premier lieu il est erroné d'évoquer la
jeunesse dans son ensemble il n'y a pas
d' attitude collective l'origine
socioprofessionnelle
les études poursuivies la situation
familiale
autant de critères qui oriente les
comportements les jeunes c'est à dire
les moins de 25 ans représentent 40% de
la population française des jeunes
comptent pour est schématiquement divisé
en plus et moins de 20 ans d'une part et
étudiants et travailleurs d'autres pas
première constatation les plus jeunes
paraissent bien plus optimistes que
leurs aînés ainsi les deux tiers des
lycéens sont satisfaits de leurs études
55% estiment que leur vie sera plus
heureuse que celle de leurs parents et
80 % déclarent qu'ils ont de bonnes
relations avec leurs parents
ce qui compte le plus la liberté et
trouver un métier intéressant
six étudiants et jeunes travailleurs ont
souvent nous l'avons dit des
préoccupations différentes
ils sont en général plus pessimistes que
les lycéens inquiets sur leur place dans
la société et surtout sur leur avenir
faut-il préciser que 44 % des demandeurs
d'emploi ont moins de 25 ans et que
parmi eux on compte un certain nombre de
diplômés la politique enfin là encore
les plus et moins de 20 ans ont des
réactions différentes
contrairement aux étudiants et jeunes
travailleurs qui penche pour
l'opposition
les lycéens se prononce plutôt pour la
majorité mais chez les moins de 20 ans
le scepticisme est quasi générale à
l'égard des partis politiques
beaucoup jugent que la politique est
importante mais qu'elle est dévoyée ces
constatations ne doivent pas pour autant
dissimuler l'existence de minorités une
proportion non négligeable de jeunes se
dit insatisfait inquiète mal dans sa
peau en opposition avec la société
et là encore la préoccupation principale
reste le chômage et la crise de l'emploi
[Musique]